in order for our bodies to function
properly the ph of our blood has to be
within a fairly a fairly narrow range
our ph so the ph of blood
needs to be between
7.35 and
7.45 if you get if the ph falls below
7.35
you're going to be diagnosed and you
know this this line is is you know
there's kind of a gray area here but
this is what's defined by the medical
community if your phd falls below 7.35
you're actually you're actually
diagnosed with acidosis
your blood is becoming too acidic you
have too high of a hydrogen ion
concentration in your blood or a
hydronium concentration in your blood if
your ph if the ph in your blood gets
above
7.45 you're diagnosed with alkalosis
alkalosis your blood is too alkaline
it's becoming too basic the the hydrogen
concentration hydrogen ion concentration
in your blood is getting too low
and so you might say wow you know this
feels like a fairly narrow range how
does how does blood how does our body
put up with
acidic things acidic molecules entering
our blood or or basic molecules entering
our blood how can it handle that without
our ph being able
while keeping our ph in this range right
over here and the answer lies in
something that's also useful for the
transportation of carbon dioxide in our
blood and this right over here this
these equilibrium reactions we see that
carbon dioxide when you put it in the
blood which is primarily water so carbon
dioxide and aqueous solution
it will react and we have some enzymes
that help this that help this along but
it will react to form carbonic acid so
let me write this down it will react to
form carbonic acid which is a weak acid
this is carbonic acid and then that can
dissociate to form a bicarbonate
so let me write that over here by
carbonate
bicarbonate and
and a hydrogen ion or when we know that
that would just attach to a water
molecule and become a hydronium ion and
so why is this useful well i said it's
actually part of the carbon dioxide
transportation in the blood because
based on the sources i've looked at
about about five to ten percent of your
carbon dioxide can just dissolve in the
blood and then also another roughly five
or ten percent can actually can actually
can actually be bound to hemoglobin and
be transported that way but the bulk of
it actually needs to go through needs to
actually be be transformed needs to
react to become carbonic acid and
bicarbonate in order to be transported
in fact in your blood the most of the
carbon dioxide in your blood is actually
in this form right over here and in
particular bicarbonate and the sources i
look at it eighty to ninety percent of
the carbon dioxide in your blood is
being transported in these forms and
primarily and primarily as bicarbonate
so this isn't the topic of this video
is that what's a useful way to transfer
to transport carbon dioxide in your
blood but this is why this is how we do
it but the topic of this video is why
this is also useful for maintaining our
blood ph in this range because these
equilibrium reactions between carbon
dioxide carbonic acid and bicarbonate
this is a buffer system
this is a
buffer
this is a buffer system and the word
buffer in our everyday language it
refers to something that that that kind
of smooths the impact of something or it
reduces the shock of something and
that's exactly what's happening here
let's think about remember these are all
equilibrium reactions this is a weak
acid and you can even look at the the
different constituents of these
molecules and account for them you have
one carbon here one carbon here one
carbon there you have one two three
oxygens there you have one two three
oxygens there one two three oxygens
there you have two hydrogens two
hydrogens two hydrogens but let's just
think about what if you started dumping
hydrogen ions in the blood so what if
you what if you what if you were to dump
what if you were to dump hydrogen ions
what's going to happen
well if you dump more hydrogen ions if
this right over here
increases
well if actually let me put it this way
if you were to just dump hydrogen ions
and if you didn't have this buffer
system then your ph would decrease your
ph would go down and if you do it enough
your ph you would end up with acidosis
but lucky for us we have this buffer
system and so if you increase if you
increase your hydrogen ion
concentrations le
challentalier's principle tells us hey
these equilibrium reactions are going to
move to the left so the more the more
hydrogen ions you have sitting in the
blood the more likely they're going to
bump into the bicarbonate in just the
right way to form carbonic acid and the
more carbonic acid that you have in the
blood well it's the less likely that
you're going to have the carbon dioxide
reacting with the water to form more
carbo carbonic acid so as you add as you
add more hydrogen ions they're just
going to be sopped up
by the bicarbonate so this equilibrium
the set of equilibrium reactions is
going to move to the left so you're not
going to have as big effect on ph and
similarly if you if you dumped if you
dumped some base let's say you dumped
you dumped some base in your in your
blood right over here well instead of it
just making instead of just making your
ph go up and possibly give you alkalosis
well now the base is going to sop up the
hydrogen ions and typically that would
just make your ph go up but if you have
if you have the if you have these things
going down well then you have fewer of
these to react and have the equilibrium
reaction go to the left and so the
reaction is going to move more and more
to the right and so this reaction you're
just going to have more carbon dioxide
being converted to carbonic acid being
converted to bicarbonate this whole
thing is going to move to the right and
so it's going to be able to some degree
replace the lost hydrogen ions so this
right over here's a buffer system
it helps dampen the impact is if you
have more hydrogen ions enter the system
or if you have something sopping up all
of the hydrogen ions and it's super
important for us well just just being
able to live and frankly all mammalian
systems